but what if you wanted to call a
function and it didn't happen to be
stored as a property of the object that
you want the parameter this to be bound
to so imagine this function looks great
but the keyword this is supposed to
refer to a specific object and that
specific object doesn't have this
function as a property there would be no
way in that situation to address this
function as the given object dot
anything if this isn't stored as a
property there's no key you can use on
that object in order to access the
function besides the left of the dot
rule that we just described there's
actually another way for you to specify
the value that you'd like the parameter
this to give bound to let's make a copy
of that previous line which had the
effect of assigning global as the
default binding for this and we'll edit
the line with an attempt to specify
exactly what we'd like this function to
bind the keyword this to by using a
functions dot call method we get to
override the default binding to global
and override the left of the dot rule in
this case we'll pass in any value we
want and it'll get bound to the keyword
this when using call we pass in one
extra value at the beginning of the
argument list and that value will be
bound to the parameter this so what
would happen if we use dot call on a
function that was also being accessed as
a property here we're using dot Col to
pass in this new yellow object but that
method was already found as a property
of the red object